da ist mein land da wird man da rein
geschubst und dann sitzt man da
[Musik]
ich bin heute zu besuch in der
untersuchungshaftanstalt des
ministeriums für staatssicherheit von
1951 bis 1989 saßen hinter diesen mauern
mehr als 10.000 politische gefangene der
ehemaligen ddr
[Musik]
andreas meeh stäube heute 54 ist einer
von ihnen er war erst 21 als er nach
versuchter republikflucht hier in haft
kam er erzählt mir von den zermürbung
strategien damals wenn er nicht gerade
vernommen wurde musste er stundenlang
auf dem hocker in seiner zelle sitzen
muss
und auch nicht so ordentlich aber 87 wo
ich da war schon annehmen und dann
gelegentlich man die augen zumachen
das wurde man nicht mal vom band rollt
manchmal auch nicht isolationshaft
ständige ungewissheit gezielte
desorientierung das ziel den willen der
gefangenen brechen und sie zu einem
geständnis bringen weiße folter nennt
man diese methode die die stasi
perfektioniert hatte was haben sie denn
den ganzen tag irgendwann habe ich da
und dort gesessen und funktioniert und
dann ist klar dass man sich freut wenn
die tür aufgeht
bis dann um was passiert was auch immer
vacha oder sommer völlig egal vielleicht
auch erschossen werden es freut man sich
dass die tür aufgehen dass irgendwas
passiert zählt man irgendwann den
karossen und die haut in einer heizungs
verkleidung
aber irgendwann auch damit auf ist
einfach langweilig so
in dieser zelle sind für mich schon
wenige minuten schwer zu ertragen
andreas mail steuergerät früh ins visier
der staatsmacht nach der schule will der
matrose werden und die welt sehen
doch er weigert sich seinen pflicht
wehrdienst freiwillig zu verlängern
er geht nicht zur wahl und dann werden
ihm auch noch westkontakte unterstellt
schon bevor er inhaftiert wurde war er
jahrelang repressalien ausgesetzt
nachdem er ein berufsverbot bekommt
plant er mit 21 jahren seine flucht über
die grenze in der tschechoslowakei
der versuch misslingt er wird verhaftet
den himmel sieht er nur noch beim
freigang auf 4 mal 10 metern
da ist nicht viel das ist nicht so viel
allein bis zum den schuhkarton aber
einmal am tag gefühlte 50 minuten super
einfach ein bisschen frisch regierung
ist alles erst mal den immer sehr genau
hinsehen regen ich kenne niemanden der
gesagt er möchte dir aus so selbst zu
schlichten bedankt das ist einfach was
anderes als in der zelle prinzip
belohnung wie so ein hund der jeden
morgen mit der inderin zur gleichen zeit
gassi geht seit 2008 zehn macht der
ehemalige sozialarbeiter führungen in
der gedenkstätte des stasi-gefängnisses
immer wieder lässt er andere an seinen
erfahrungen teilhaben
er kämpft wie viele opfer des regimes
gegen das vergessen und dafür dass dem
betroffenen endlich gerechtigkeit
widerfährt von 17 millionen ddr bürger
insgesamt so gehabt sind vielleicht 13
vielleicht auch 14 millionen vielleicht
aufrufs millionen keine ahnung ganz
sauber durch grund spricht zurzeit mit
einer riesigen portion glück heißen
gegönnt werden diese leute heute sich
hinstellen und sagen ach das war doch
schön wir hatten eine wohnung die
bezahlbar war wir hatten arbeit
uns ging es doch gut kann ich das
nachvollziehen aber es gab tatsächlich
etwas anderes und das findet
gesellschaftlich überhaupt gar nicht und
das ist eigentlich ziemlich schräg das
schlimmste erfährt er erst jahre nach
seiner verhaftung erzählt mir andreas
meeh steuber die staatssicherheit hatte
ihn bereits seit seinem sechzehnten
lebensjahr bespitzelt er hatte keine
ahnung wer der inoffizielle mitarbeiter
war der alle informationen lieferte
damit mail stoppel verhaftet werden
konnte
wir gehen in den raum in dem er während
der haft täglich stundenlang vernommen
wurde
nach kaspers ihre stasi-akte in seiner
akte steht auch wer der spitzel war
michaels vater und wann wussten sie das
was der vater getan hat 290 daten an
sich ja das fand ich dann schon ziemlich
niederschmetternd und zwar nicht
aufgrund des umstandes ist das gemacht
hat sondern eher wie also wenn man sich
die berichte durchliest wird ein
eigentlich schlecht zum beispiel das ist
einfach sehr man könnte denken wir
schreibt über die man anders nicht über
sein sohn privilegien bekam der vater
dafür nicht mehr stoppen kann bis heute
nicht erklären warum sein vater ihm das
angetan hat es ihr vater dann für sie
auch täter ja natürlich
was uns
inhalt keiner dazu gezwungen sieben
monate nach seiner verhaftung kommt
andreas meeh stäube dank einer amnestie
frei kurz darauf darf er in die
bundesrepublik ausreisen
anderthalb jahre später fällt die mauer
schon damals ahnte er dass seine
peiniger nicht zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden würden
das war mir völlig klar dass die dass
diese vergesslichkeit sofort mit dem c
november ist sie angetreten
der täter sind dick bin nach definitiv
das muss man schon sagen
[Musik]